this is sasha johnson a prominent
anti-racism campaigner she's fighting
for her life in hospital after
reportedly being shot in the head
the incident happened in southwark in
southeast london
police were called to an address on
consort road behind me at just after
three o'clock in the morning on sunday
it is there they say they found a 27
year old woman who had suffered from a
gunshot wound
detectives from the metropolitan
police's specialist crime command are
leading the investigation
in a statement the met says while the
investigation is at an early stage
there is nothing to suggest the woman
who was shot was the subject of a
targeted attack
or that she had received any credible
threats against her prior to this
incident
last august sasha johnson organised
large-scale march
to protest against systemic racism she
told sky news what drives her activism
the uk disassociates from racism but we
have to remember
the wind rush generation came here when
we're funding water bomb other countries
and people are coming here for safety
and rest
then we're flewing them away with our
xenophobia so we're not disassociating
from we're saying yes is here
we need to address it now we're in 2020.
we've come too far
for racism to still be a problem the 27
year old mother is a committee member of
the political party
taking the initiative the party says
it is with great sadness that we inform
you that our own sasha johnson
has sustained a gunshot wound to her
head
sasha has always been actively fighting
for black people
and the injustices that surround the
black community
so far there have been no arrests police
are appealing to anyone with any
information to come forward
jemima walker sky news